hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the Paul
Morphy saga and I know what you are all
thinking you're thinking if this is the
Staunton challenge video why is there
this Samuel Standage Bowdoin person here
instead of instead of Stanton we will
get to that it might take us a while but
we're definitely gonna get there and I
would just like to mention in the
previous video a lot of you realized
this I myself haven't when I presented
not this but when I presented all of
morpheus games that he played during his
stay in the in New York in 1857 that I
said that he wants some games against
against his rival Paulsen with games
games a lot but I misinterpreted the
table so as you can see those games
he'll Morphy one with with also for
example with Queens Knight odds were
against parent not against Paulsen so
even games around the left games of odds
are on the right so I I missed that for
some reason I did think it was weird
when I mentioned it but I thought maybe
there were some maybe games behind
closed doors where we didn't have the
movies and maybe they had a lot of wine
I don't know but yeah definitely he did
not play any games at odds against
Paulson so I just wanted to mention that
and also I mentioned in the previous
video that the game we've shown was
actually game 5 of the match between
morphine Stanley when in fact it was a
game one so it wasn't like I said first
games won by more feet than game 5 drawn
it was actually first game drawn and
then four games won by Murphy so no idea
no idea how I mix that up but just
putting it out there and thanks for
everyone to everyone for reminding me
now getting back to our stuntman
challenge so more if he spent some three
and a half months in New York doing 1857
and he played all those games and then
he returned of course the to New Orleans
hour he received a nice welcome they had
a party everyone was very excited to see
Murphy and just became even more popular
in New Orleans they had a lot more new
members everyone well was happy to be in
the same place as Murphy was and Murphy
started playing a lot more chess he
started the throwing
more simultaneous exhibitions he played
games a lot and the challenge he threw
at the Newark chess club that he will
play anyone at the odds of a pawn and
the move he now shifted to the entire to
the entire United States not just in New
York and he said that he will play
anyone on those terms with a hundred
dollars per stake and no one accepted
this offer and then the members of the
New Orleans Chess Club issued a
challenge to none other than Howard
fountain so here the challenge taught
him to imagine they said that Morphy
would very gladly visit England but due
to some family issues he is unable to
travel at the moment and that they would
enjoy if Staunton came to New Orleans
for the match to be played there and
there were 10 10 points of the match a
world 10 terms but only three of them
are are basically the important ones for
us it's that the match will be played at
$5,000 a stake so Stanton would have to
present $5,000 if he wanted to face more
fee and even if Stanton lost he would
still be reimbursed 1,000 dollars to
cover traveling expenses and the idea
acceptance of the match also it would be
probably after more fees a match against
Louie paulsen it would not be allowed to
think more than half an hour for one
move and another another term I found
interesting was that Murphy and Stanton
were to be given exclusive rights for
the publishing of the games no one else
so it would be there you know right and
privilege to do with with their games
and their moves as they please but
Stanton replied some a few months after
that via Telegraph that he's unable to
accept the match on those turns that
Stanton is extremely busy now and he's
he hasn't been playing a professional
chess for quite some time now and it
would take him some time let's say a
month the birth to brush up on his
skills but he's currently so busy that
he cannot simply leave work and travel
to New Orleans to accept such a match
but okay some
some time passed and the Morphy decided
that he will he will go to the England
he was invited to the Birmingham chess
meeting and he accepted their birthday
invitation first more fees family said
that he shouldn't go that his he will
soon be accepted in the bar he will soon
be soon be able to start practicing
being a lawyer as that's you know what
he's supposed to do but he said that he
would very much enjoy going to Europe
and challenging some masters there and
also to attend the famous at Birmingham
chess meeting so Morphy departed for for
Birmingham but in that exact moment I
think it was a day after Murphy actually
left that Staunton challenged Morphy to
a match via Telegraph he said that since
there's a he cannot if more he cannot
come to England and Staunton cannot come
to to New Orleans that they should
organise a match via Telegraph and such
match were all wretches were already
organized not not on such a long
distance it was more of a city next to
see detail at Telegraph machen but never
on such such a big distance
but since Morphy already left for
England he could not accept that and
Moorefield later said that if he knew
that Stanton was gonna challenge him to
a telegraph match that he would
definitely stay and postpone is his trip
to England but okay morphia arrives I
think he first arrived in Liverpool then
he went to Birmingham and when he
arrived to Birmingham everyone who heard
of Morphy they expected like this really
you know big muscular dude with facial
hair you know very very strong
expression but morphe was nothing of the
sort
and then when morphe came to Birmingham
they took him to a photographer and they
made a very nice portrait of him if and
they hanged it in the Birmingham chess
club so if you are maybe from Birmingham
and you have access to Birmingham Chess
Club maybe you can check if Morpheus
portrait is still there and share with
us in the comments that would be that
would be pretty great
the problem was the Birmingham just
meeting that Morphy so hastily you know
rushed into was supposed to start some
two days after more fees arrival to
Birmingham but then they switched it it
was supposed to be in June and they
switch it to August so morphe really
arrived prematurely to the event and
then he had he had a lot of free time on
his hands
so he he did have he wasn't really a
good sailor he was he was a very sick
when he arrived so it took him some time
to to recover but he then decided to go
to London he wants to London and he met
Staunton there Howard something the the
strongest player in England and you know
among the strongest player players in
Europe and the Morphy was a guest at
Stanton ha a Stanton's house where
Murphy again issued a challenge at the
Howard Stanton he said okay I've arrived
I've arrived in England I challenge you
to a match now and Stanton accepted he
said okay now the problem just give me
one month to brush up on my endgame and
opening skills and we will then commence
our match with which terms to be decided
afterwards and while well they're more
if he said that maybe since they're
already here
you know Stanton shared Murphy we would
more for his food his house his
hospitality and Murphy said that maybe
they could play like a friendly game
just you know just the two of them and
stomped on declined for the moment he
was not interested in a friendly game
but he did invite two of his friends one
of them being not friends but they were
also renowned chess masters in England
Samuel Standage Bowden and mr. Barnes
you all know mr. Barnes the person who
had the best result against Murphy when
when Murphy visited England and we've
covered some games between morphine
Barnes I think some two years maybe
three years ago on this channel but we
are going to revisit them as it is
important for the more amorphous saga so
here a while in their day they enjoyed
some some consultation games they played
two against two and Morphy won all of
those games so basically more free beats
Townsend but not in a one-on-one match
and also some people say that during
this
stay there there's only two consultation
games are accounted for that it would
make sense if morphine Sutton played
some games and then maybe just never
publish them and maybe never spoke about
them but it's to 2020 so if such a thing
happened I probably it would have come
out about now but who knows
you know maybe they played some games
while a Murphy stayed at someone's house
or maybe they haven't but the morph is
first serious match well if his first
his first match when he arrived to
England was against Edward Lowe the
owner of the lost hotel where Murphy was
staying and he defeated him six to zero
and he is the first person in England
who really knew what to expect from
Morpheus he was also a good chess player
himself because none of the players they
knew Murphy was strong but they didn't
actually knew that Murphy was Morphy
strong so to say so this is one of the
games we're going to cover his first
serious opponent upon his arrival to
England is Samuel Standage Bowden so
while we are waiting to see what happens
with Stanton and the challenge we are
going to cover some of the games that
Morphy played here so Samuel Standage
Bowden if you are a chess player and I
imagine you are since you are watching
this you might have heard of Boden's
mate it's the checkmate given with two
bishops when one bishop is slicing one
way in the other the show delivers
checkmate and the Kings path to escape
is blocked by his own pieces so that the
Boden's mate and it is well attributed
to the Samuel Standage Bowden who played
it I think a few years before his match
with Morphy here but this is one of the
games we're going to cover it's the
first game of their match I'm gonna
check up on some of the other ones if
they are interesting we were going to
show a bit more games between the two of
them then we're gonna continue our saga
from there but that's enough intro for
four for one video more feet with the
white pieces against the Samuel Bowden
opens with E for Boleyn replies with E 5
and Murphy goes straight for the head he
was for the King's gambit and Bowden
declines the gambit use for Bishop to c5
which was which was a known way to
decline the Kings gambit in
those days with Knight to f3 morphic
continues development and the now d6
making room for the lights worship we
have c3 preparing a breakthrough in the
center would be for and now Bishop to g4
and as you can see Boden really did like
his bishops as he brings them into the
game before night and you know that
there's a sing in chest you should
always bring your Knights into the game
before your bishops but okay Bishop to
eat you buy more fee we have Knight to
c6 and now before grabbing more space on
the Queen side Bishop to b6 and now b5
dislodging Boylan's Knight from c6 with
Knights to a5 and now comes d4 finally
so grabbing a lot of central squares
here with Bishop captures on f3 Bishop
captures on f3 and now he captures on d4
we have C captures and the Queen to f6
now preventing any d5 ideas since the
rook would be hanging on a1 and it's
just a very nice developing move for
Bowden so black looking good here morphe
definitely against uh you know a decent
opponent we have Bishop to e3
as the d4 pawn was attacked twice and
now Knight to c4 now the night finds his
way back into the game with an attack on
the bishop on III that's undefended so
Bishop to f2 he has to abandon the
defense of the f4 pawn and here Boden
captures it maybe a slightly more
precise way would be Bishop to a5 check
forcing the King to f1 but this wasn't
this wasn't the problem in those days if
you play the Kings gambit you would also
play King f1 and then maybe a castle
artificially g3 King g2 and bring the
rook into the game this way so not
really worried about this and Bowden
doesn't seem to think that it should be
played so he goes for Queen captures on
f4 he grabs a pond and okay morphine out
castles the safety and if nothing he at
least has the same open file for his
rook now and there is actually one game
that was played after this game and
reached this exact same position where
Knight to e7 was played it's an
improvement on the game where Knight to
f6 was played it was played in 1904 but
black was still a still able
to lose this game abut okay Knight to f6
and Queen to d3 now buy morphine adding
a second defender here and pressuring
the night here and here tonight goes
back we have Knight to a5 reluctant to
go d5 to defend the knight this way
because this would maybe give more fee
attacking chances as bone and skin is
still in the center of the board so
tonight's the a5 and now comes Knight to
c3 Morpha continues developing we have
castles and now g3 pushing the Queen
back Queen to h6
and now King G to improving the position
of the king also the king will now help
out with with the defences and planning
Knight to e2 followed by Knight to f4 to
bring the knight into the game we have
rook 88 and now Murphy also was rook 81
and King to a trade quite a weird move
as there is nothing on this diagonal to
make the King go to a trade I don't know
what to make of it maybe maybe some
knight EG h the east of an action is
being played to shift the night over to
g6 but for the moment it's hard to say
more if he goes Bishop to e3 he kicks
the way the Queen back to g6 and now
Knight to e2 preparing knight to afford
to further her as the Queen so h6 Bolin
makes an escape route for his queen and
now first Bishop to b2 now the route
will also keep an eye on the pawn here
so if the point is at any moment capture
then Knight f4 just opens up a triple
attack on the knight and also the Queen
is under attack
so black just falls apart here so after
Bishop d2 we have d5 now sorry d5 by
black and now challenging Morphy Center
and here point is if you capture then
morphe will have doubled his pawns here
but black will be able to trade Queens
and the morphe doesn't mind the Queen
trade but he prefers a Queen trade on
his own terms so first Knight f4 he
improves the the position of his pieces
we have Queen back to h7 and now comes a
five so here morphe manages to save the
d4 pawn for the moment you cannot
capture because the knight would be
hanging here but also now there's the
attack on the night
f6 so here Bowdoin traits we have Queen
captures Knight captures and now instead
of moving the night first night to see
for going after morph is Bishop and e2
and here full I feel free to pause the
video and try to find what morphe had in
mind here and what is the best move best
move for white well I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
unsporting that you should create a
double attack
and for those who just won't enjoy the
show it's Bishop to b4 now the roof is
under attack and the night here and here
morphe just wins the exchange so if you
don't want to lose a piece Knight to e4
and now morphe goes for the best shot
captures and f8 with rook captures and
f8 and now Knight to f4 bringing the
knight into the game saying that if you
capture my pawn here then I'm just gonna
go for Bishop captures pawn captures and
now the deadly Knights the e6 with again
a double attack and you cannot defended
the BH were discovered by the night so
you cannot save the bishop if you
capture of course then rook captures
rook and it's just game over for black
so instead after night a4 bought and
tried Knight eat the b2 he went for the
rook on f1 also pressuring the Bishop on
f3
but now morphe just trades down into an
endgame that he feels a very confident
playing he gives back the exchange
Bishop characters on d5 we have Knight
captures on f1 now Bishop captures on c4
again attacking the knight the Knight
has to go back only move Knight to e2
and now burst back to d5 getting away
from the knight and also putting
pressure on the b7 pawn and here
Boden's last last hope is g5 you have to
kick away the night from here but his
spidey sense didn't go off instead he
played Bishop characters and before
accepting expecting Bishop captures on
b7 from morphe but once again while I
have a nice sip of my water feel free to
pause the video and win this game for
white well I'll give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on pushing the pawn
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show of course it is east six
point is black is unable to react that
is because if you capture an IG six
check it just wins wins the game on the
spot and of course if you go Rocky eight
then just captures on f7 and once the
rock moves it's just a very nice mate
you don't even have to bring a queen
into the game you could also go for a
nice double-double nights mate check
King has to go here and then you bring
another Knight into the game with
checkmate as the knight and Bishop
covered these squares and the two
knights guard each other very very
poetic mate so after each six with g5
this is Borden's last attempt yes he
should have done before grabbing the
pawn on d4 but now just east 7 by
morphine will Brook the eight and out
Bishop captures an f7 going after the
rook there G captures an F for morphic
conduit captures as the next movie will
capture the rook or the rook moves he
brings the Queen into the game and now
you Borden can either try something like
this give up the rook and go into this
endgame where more if you would have a
rook and Bishop against the bishop in
night and the bull and of course knows
that Morphy is more than capable of
winning this
so here Bohdan instead of resigning he
played rook captures on e7 and after
morphe recaptured he resigned here not
really sure why he did this first but
[Music]
probably for he had a good reason for
this I don't know what the reason is but
he probably did have it so this is the
first game between poor Charles Murphy
and Samuel Standish Bowden they played
10 games 11 if you count also the
simultaneous game Morphy played against
five chess masters in a simultaneous
exhibition and Bowden was again again
one of the the participants and he
defeated him there but out of the 10
games they played in this match morphe
won 6-3 of the games were drawn and one
game was won by Boland and I still have
to decide whether we're gonna show more
of them or not I'm gonna I'm gonna check
them out and then we're gonna see what
what it's going to do and as
Bohdan was the story I just prepared a
one letter that I would just like to
read as Boden was one of the first to
experience more fees real strength here
is the letter he wrote he says let us do
lets us do mr. Murphy full justice he's
beyond question one of the finest
players living and we may fairly
question whether he will meet with his
superior he possesses singular coolness
along with a great concentrate
concentrated if power is deliberate but
not by any means slow and the great
depth of insight he unites a rapidity
and faculty in combination which we have
not seen surpassed his memory is a
remarkably tenacious and the UH nearing
truth and force with which he pursues an
advantage once obtained have excited the
admiration of the best players in London
his style of play is attacking and
brilliant occasionally rather over
hazardous but he possesses a steadiness
which when we consider his youth is
marvelous we heartily congratulate our
chess brethren in America upon the skill
and chivalry of their young champion he
possesses a truly gigantic capacity for
chess which has which was never fully
called forth because even its partial
development suffice to enable him to
triumph over all opponents so as you can
see even he understood that Murphy is
nowhere near his full strength at Murphy
is only as good as he needs to be at to
defeat his opponents now but the work
we're definitely going to cover more of
the games from his visit and we are
still we still have to check up on what
happened with with the challenge to
stand on as we do go on with this yeah
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it took us a bit longer as we
had to cover what happened after the
first American chess congress he's
returned to New Orleans and then
everything coming up to the match with
Stanton but as its it is a lot to take
in the video took up a bit longer but
that's why we have the sagas for to
enjoy more chess yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Doug
Doug was Prince Johnny Olsen a shy gross
Joe Hagen Ross and Matthew Finn for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Murphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day